PAUL KINLAN: Hi.
Everyone.
Welcome to "Two Pauls
in a Pod" show.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes!
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
We wanted to say this.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm Paul Lewis.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
You nearly forgot who you
were there for a second?
PAUL LEWIS: No, well, I didn't
know if you were going to
carry on talking.
I thought it'd be better
if I just jumped
in there, you know?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I got you.
OK, so yeah, he's Paul Lewis.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm a developer advocate.
You're a programming engineer.
PAUL LEWIS: I am.
PAUL KINLAN: We're working on
the Chrome apps initiative.
We're based in London in
a really small room.
We have an awesome producer,
Mark Lunney, who's completely
off screen at the moment.
But I just thought I'd
try and embarrass
him live on the stage.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
I like how you said that we're
in this little room in London.
It makes it sound like
that's where we live.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, it's
not really full-time
two Pauls in a pod.
It could be, though.
That'd be weird.
PAUL KINLAN: I wouldn't mind.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, yeah.
So--
PAUL KINLAN: On that note--
PAUL LEWIS: Let's carry on.
PAUL KINLAN: On that note,
let's carry on.
So today's episode is
about the Chrome
apps window in APIs.
Chrome apps is a new
platform that we're
building into Chrome.
It's not yet in Stable.
It's in Canary and Developer
channel.
But we believe it's going to
give you the ability to build
great web applications in the
future, applications that can
do way more than a traditional
web application could do.
So we can access network,
UDP, TCP, all
those types of things.
But the thing that we want to
try and do is tell you how you
can build great applications
which use multiple windows.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: I think on the web
today we don't really have
that many applications that
use multiple windows.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
PAUL KINLAN: Mostly single-page
web applications.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, I think,
taking a step back, we're used
to pop-up blockers and things
because multiple windows or
pop-ups or whatever have been
a bit of a nuisance.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So because we're
in the Chrome apps
environment, we're actually able
to kind of reassess that
and say, well, actually,
multi-windows make sense for
certain applications when you
say you've got panels to the
side of your main view
or whatever.
So I guess that's where
it kind of comes from.
PAUL KINLAN: It's things
like-- you
know Photoshop, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Uh-huh.
PAUL KINLAN: People expect
like a tools
pop-up out to the side.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
that's right.
PAUL KINLAN: You have multiple
image windows and all that
type of stuff.
How would you build an
application that orchestrates
actions between them?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: I would just like
to add before we get into the
code, Paul's going to show you
some really cool demos and
everything like that.
One is we have down below.
We're trying it.
Well, Paul's got it
completely wrong.
But right down below,
we have--
PAUL LEWIS: I have not.
It's over there, right?
There it is.
PAUL KINLAN: There it is.
PAUL LEWIS: Hey, I was just
pointing to the bottom.
PAUL KINLAN: We would like
your questions, right?
We want to basically answer as
many questions as possible
during this session, just so
we can provide you with the
best guidance possible.
So if you check our Google link,
you'll go straight to
our Moderator page.
And you'll be able to vote on
questions that you like, down
vote some that you don't like.
We only have one question
so far.
So I'm expecting at
least 10 today.
But yeah, just get
asking questions.
We also have our colleague
in Brazil, Renato.
"Henato," I think, is the proper
way of pronouncing it.
Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: I stand corrected.
PAUL KINLAN: Anyway, he'll
be moderating some of the
questions as well as any of the
YouTube questions and all
those types of things.
But please feel free.
This is a live show unless
you're watching this tomorrow.
PAUL LEWIS: In which
case, it's not
Google Developers Live.
It's Google Developers
recorded.
PAUL KINLAN: But we'll
answer as many
questions as we can today.
And if we can't answer them,
we'll try and roll them over
to next week's episode.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
Should we go into some code?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
What editor do you
use, by the way?
PAUL LEWIS: I use
Sublime Text.
PAUL KINLAN: Sublime Text.
PAUL LEWIS: Everytime we get
asked that-- there we go.
That's the one.
It's the one.
You use Vim, do you not?
PAUL KINLAN: I'm a Vim man.
PAUL LEWIS: You're a
Vim improved man.
PAUL KINLAN: I used to like
VIM until the drink.
That's how it kind of--
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
You didn't choose your interests
based on the drink
that you liked as a child?
PAUL KINLAN: No.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
Good.
I'm glad we had that
conversation.
PAUL KINLAN: So I always say
that I'm preparing a joke
every single episode.
PAUL LEWIS: Every time.
PAUL KINLAN: This one
has been a couple of
weeks in the planning.
All right.
Let's get going.
PAUL LEWIS: So sorry.
PAUL KINLAN: Sorry about this.
Let's look at the code.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
let's do it. .
OK.
So I have the code
up on screen.
Now what I've done is I've taken
the liberty of actually
starting the app
ahead of time.
So there's a lot of stuff that
we've covered in previous
weeks about boilerplating,
getting up to speed with some
code and all the rest of it.
So I didn't want
to repeat that.
You can find those in the
samples on GitHub, And you can
also watch previous weeks.
So I'm in the main JS, which
is the background page.
This is the hub of your
apps activity.
And as you can see,
I'm actually
creating three windows.
So I'm actually creating
three of them with
index.html as the source.
And then I'm just positioning
them across the screen.
And they're identical apart from
the fact that I'm pushing
on variables.
Now, the way to talk
to a window.
So the window that gets passed
back as this in the callback
function is an app window, which
isn't the same as the
DOM window that you're
used to dealing with.
So we actually access the DOM
window inside the app window
using the content
window property.
There you go.
That's a fun way of
explaining it.
PAUL KINLAN: So we can't really
do this in the web
today, right?
PAUL LEWIS: No, not
that I know of.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, we can
do it with iFrames.
But it's--
PAUL LEWIS: It's a bit weird.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's not a generally
well-accepted way of--
PAUL LEWIS: No.
So you can see what I'm doing,
though, is I'm getting the
window passed back as a part
where the callback.
I'm accessing content window,
which gets me into the DOM of
the window that I created.
Then I'm setting this window
name property on there.
And I'm obviously calling one
Left, one Mid, and one Right.
And the last thing I'm doing
is I'm actually pushing it
onto an array of wins, which is
basically what I'm going to
do or what I'm going to use
later on to actually talk to
the window.
So let me just show you what
this looks like right now.
There we are.
The windows, they're
all the same.
Deal?
Left, mid, and right, although
you can't really tell that
it's Left, Mid and Right,
particularly.
They just say Window.
So the first thing that I wanted
to actually do is in
the source of index.html, you'll
see the markup for what
I just showed you, which is this
sort of the window, the
form, and an output area,
and an index.js file.
Now, what we want to do in this
app if we can is have a
setup where if I type a message
in here and say hello
and submit it, that it actually
does something.
That it actually takes that
message and puts it into the
current window that I'm looking
at, but it also shows
it up in the other two windows,
kind of, I suppose,
like a chat kind of mechanism,
I suppose.
So the first thing I want to
actually do is I want to pick
up the injected variable.
Let me just find
that over here.
So the injected property name--
property, sorry--
window name.
I want to pick that up
inside that window.
And I want to use it
to set the title.
So you can see I have in the
markup a span inside the H1
called title.
What I want to do in here-- as
you can see, I've also picked
it up in the JavaScript.
So what I'm actually going to
do is say title.textContent
equals this-- because this
is going to refer
to the window object--
windowname.
So that's the variable
I injected.
So now if I reload the
application, hopefully, Window
Left, Window Mid,
Window Right.
So this is the first
kind of way of
dealing with this stuff.
You can actually inject
variables into your Windows.
Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: I think we talked
briefly about this last week,
didn't we, with Intent data, but
We didn't really allude to
what was happening.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
PAUL KINLAN: Last week's talk
was about Web Intents Oh,
we're on camera!
PAUL LEWIS: We're back.
PAUL KINLAN: So last week was
about Web Intents and how to
deliver data between windows.
And this is the same type
of way, isn't it?
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
You just push that right in.
And I think that is a bit
unusual for web developers
from that typical web
development background is to
just kind of inject things.
And certainly what I'm going to
show you in a little bit is
using post message as well,
which is a lot more, I think,
what people are used to.
You can do it either way.
So that's the thing.
So it's really done to you as
to how you want to do this.
So back to the code.
The main thing we need to do
here is sending messages.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to send--
when you submit the form on
one of those windows, I'm
going to take that input, and
I'm going to pass it to the
background page.
And then the background page is
going to send that message
out to all the windows.
So the background page,
as I said before, is
acting as the hub.
So everything goes via
the background page.
And that's the model that I
think you need to get used to
if you're going to
make Chrome apps.
So the first thing I need to do
because form submission is
not accepted.
It's not something that we
support in the Chrome Apps.
I need to say the event--
because you can see I've got a
form submission event.
I'm going to say event.prevent
default.
So that's going to stop
the form from
actually being submitted.
But it does mean that I capture
the fact that they've
submitted the form.
PAUL KINLAN: I have
a quick question.
PAUL LEWIS: Go for it.
PAUL KINLAN: Are you a tabs
guy or a spaces guy?
PAUL LEWIS: I'm a spaces guy.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
Good.
PAUL LEWIS: But each to
their own, you know?
It's a personal preference
thing, isn't it?
So the thing I want to
do is I want to say--
let me just do this.
If I've got the background page,
and I want to call a
function on the background page
called broadcast, and I'm
going to say this.windowname,
and then whatever was in the
box at the time.
And then I'm going to
set whatever was
in the box to nothing.
So there's a couple
of things here.
The background page is currently
set to null, so I
don't actually have a reference
to the page.
Now you could use window.opener
as one option.
But because there's actually
something built into the
Chrome runtime, which
we can use.
So we're going to
do that instead.
We're going to actually do--
let me see, now.
Chrome.runtime.g
etBackgroundPage.
PAUL KINLAN: Should we explain
a little bit more about the
background page?
PAUL LEWIS: Well, the background
page, as we said a
couple of times, is the hub.
PAUL KINLAN: That shows me
listening, doesn't it?
PAUL LEWIS: It does rather.
Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: But does
the background
page always live there?
Or does it die at any point
in the application?
PAUL LEWIS: Well, it
can get suspended.
But typically, it's there
all the time.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so
it's a good, little
hub, as you were saying.
PAUL LEWIS: It is a
good little hub.
So because the getBackgroundPage
takes a
callback function.
I have passed that in there,
as you can see.
And what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use
backgroundPage equals page.
So I'm going to set that given
whatever I've got returned.
So hopefully now, by the time
sendMessage is running, we
have BackgroundPage in place.
Now, the problem is we're
calling broadcast and we don't
have that function in there.
So we better go ahead
and add that.
Now, this is where I'm
actually going to use
postMessage to talk
to the window.
So I've got this message
being picked up.
I'm sending it to the background
page and saying can
you broadcast this to all
the other windows?
So in main JS, which is my
background page, I just throw
in a function called
broadcast.
And I'm going to have
it take a message.
And then I'm going to go through
all of the windows
that I put onto that
array before.
Views less than wins, length,
go through all windows.
I always write my four
loops like that.
Some people write some very,
very crazy four loops.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So Eric Bidelman showed me a way
that we don't have to use
the length property,
but it auto assigns
wins to a win object.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, I like this.
PAUL KINLAN: --a while ago.
Yeah, I'd never seen
that before.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
OK.
PAUL KINLAN: Again,
each to his own.
He's super nice, actually.
He's pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, I'll have
to ask him about that.
So as you remember from before,
I was actually pushing
on the app window.
I was pushing the app window
reference onto the array.
I could have pushed on the
content window, the
actual DOM window on.
But I didn't.
So I have to reference it
via content window now.
And I'm just gonna
say postMessage.
And I'm just going to
pass in the message.
And then the second part
is about the origin.
So you can check that one if
you've not come across that
one before.
So I'm posting the message
through to each of the
windows, in turn.
So the last thing that needs to
actually happen is, back in
my index JS, you'll see I've
got this receiveMessage.
So I've added onto this
particular window each of
those three windows.
I've added on an event
listener for message.
When we get a message
in, we run this
receiveMessage callback.
So that's going to
take an event.
And I'm going to say output,
which if you remember, is this
text area over here.
So I've got a text
area on the page.
I'm going to say
output.textContent plus equals
the data, and then a new
line just to keep
things nice and neat.
So hopefully, all being well,
unless I've made a mistake
somewhere, when we re-load the
application, I can say hello.
And you see that Left is
now saying hello to
Left, Mid, and Right.
And go in here and say world.
And the Window Right is going
to chime in with no--
Universe.
Ha!
So there you go.
So that's the way that you
can actually have windows
communicating.
As we said, it always goes
via the background page.
That is, that you need to
treat that as a whole.
So again, just a quick
run-through.
When we send a message, in this
case, we're just calling
a function on the
background page.
But again, you could post a
message through if that was
your preferred method
of doing it.
In this case, I just decided
to call a function on the
background page.
In there, I'm actually then
picking that up and finding
each of the individual
windows and posting a
message through to them.
And then when they get our
message, they just simply
append it to the text area.
So that's kind of the
way all this works.
Obviously, we're covering
getting hold of
the background page.
And that is that.
PAUL KINLAN: I have one
question to say.
The actual Moderator questions,
I set this up wrong.
I've been disabled.
So I'm actually just working
on this whole process now.
Um, yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Hm.
So presumably, people can't
ask questions right now.
PAUL KINLAN: People can't
PAUL LEWIS: We'd like
them to, though.
PAUL KINLAN: I did
try to enable it.
I just got rid of the
deadline, so yeah,
it should be there.
It's not quite.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, sorry
about this, folks.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
sorry about this.
PAUL LEWIS: Not to worry.
PAUL KINLAN: It should
be there.
I mean, you guys, you should be
able to submit questions.
If not, I'm actually
monitoring the
actual event as well.
We mainly have--
yeah, that's pretty much it.
PAUL LEWIS: Any changes this
week in Chrome Apps?
PAUL KINLAN: There
are no changes.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes!
PAUL KINLAN: Well, there
are changes.
There've been quite
a lot of changes.
But generally, what normally
happens each week is that we
try and give you a breakdown
of breaking changes, things
that have kind of happened
inside the APIs where you have
to change your code.
This week, especially around the
window in API, there is no
changes of note, at least.
All your apps should work.
I think what we're going to
do for the next couple of
episodes at least is start
demonstrating more real-world
applications.
We have a couple on GitHub.
So we're not going to go
directly into the APIs and do
this kind of conversation
anymore.
Well, we will.
We'll have conversations.
And we'll have Moderator
questions that work.
PAUL LEWIS: Whoa.
Whoa.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
I apologize about this
profusely, profusely.
PAUL LEWIS: Good.
PAUL KINLAN: But there have
been no changes this week.
There might be some next week.
We don't quite know.
But we'll let you know.
PAUL LEWIS: But generally,
actually if you want us to
cover anything specifically
alongside the apps that we're
going to take a deep dive
into, just let us know.
You can do that in the Moderator
when it works.
Or you can post to the
comments on Google+.
Or you can tweet in our general
direction as well.
PAUL KINLAN: So we do have some
things coming through.
Oh, thanks, the questions
are up.
So Hemanna--
I hope I've pronounced
your name right.
If you have any questions,
please submit them.
We have also a question
from Josh Libby,
which I believe I answered.
There is no captioning
on live content.
So what happens at the end of
this, we'll produce it and
publish it, push it live onto
YouTube, where there will be
some automatic transcription and
transcription of the show.
PAUL LEWIS: Of the video.
PAUL KINLAN: It's pretty cool.
They can translate Scouse
and Burnley.
PAUL LEWIS: Burnley.
PAUL KINLAN: Burnley.
PAUL LEWIS: In case anybody
from outside the United
Kingdom is watching, which I'm
sure you are, I'm from an area
called Burnley, which
is the source of his
mockery, which is good.
PAUL KINLAN: I wasn't
mockering.
PAUL LEWIS: Why not?
PAUL KINLAN: Mockering?
PAUL LEWIS: Mockering.
PAUL KINLAN: I can't
even speak.
So anyway--
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
A good question is--
PAUL KINLAN: I actually wanted
to ask some questions to you
about patterns and practices for
multi-window applications.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: So you showed
basically calling the method
directly on the background
page.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Would you use
that over post message?
PAUL LEWIS: I think it depends
on the application.
I have no strong feelings.
For me, personally, I'm very
used to the web developer kind
of methodology of decoupling.
And for me to some degree,
it's a change in mindset.
There's a lot of change in
mindset that are required for
Chrome Apps.
And I think this
is one of them.
I'm sort of making my peace
with the fact that I have
control over these windows.
I should expect them to
be there because I'm
in control of that.
I'm not expecting pop-up
blockers to get in the way and
those kinds of things.
I'm OK with it.
I don't think there's any
particular problem there.
It is a different model.
And if you were building a
native application on the
platform, it would be weird to
not be able to just kind of
hook directly in
and talk to it.
So I'm OK with it, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I'm just curious.
Because I've seen this thing
before, where we've had like
magic iFrames, which if you look
for documentation about
what a magic iFrame is--
PAUL LEWIS: I don't
know what it is.
PAUL KINLAN: It's magic.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh!
PAUL KINLAN: So basically, the
idea was that you want to have
one piece of logic, like the
background page inside these
applications, live inside
your web app.
And say it was a new mail
application that you had, and
you opened it up to
run your email.
You don't want the cold start
time of that new window to be
horrendously long.
You want all the code to
be there straightaway.
And when you were showing
that, you were basically
calling and passing in methods
and data into a newly opened
window, I think it was kind
of a similar thing where
basically you would say this
is my background page.
Push it onto this new window.
PAUL LEWIS: Ah, so you're
smooshing in.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, you're
kind of smooshing in
all the logic, basically.
PAUL LEWIS: Like as sort of a
primer or starter thing, like
go with this, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, cool.
PAUL KINLAN: And that was
basically designed to get rid
of that kind of massive overhead
of download and
assets and everything, which
doesn't necessarily apply
here, but we now have
a centralized
resource for app logic.
And I think that actually
brings onto--
the question from Hemanna
HM from Bangalore.
"Is NVC dead?
Should we move on?"
PAUL LEWIS: No.
PAUL KINLAN: No, I think it's
more relevant and applicable
to these types of
applications.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, you can inject
controllers into these.
You could have a central
controller and then treat
these as views.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So we were talking about this
the other day, weren't we?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Where we were
basically saying that the
traditional model for web
applications is to build a
single-page application and
manage the views inside that.
And we're not saying that this
is ever going to go away.
We're saying that you have the
ability to basically go
outside the normal single page
app and have multiple windows
and do tool pilots like
on Photoshop and all
those types of things.
But how do you develop
those applications?
Well, by the fact that we have
access to the window object
that we've created, we were
talking about whether we could
do what the magic iFrame did.
You kind of smoosh HTML and
JavaScript from one window
into another window with
logic or with CS--
well, maybe not with CSS, but
basically enough of the
construct to say, well, it's
an empty window until you
inject data into it, and
content, and logic.
PAUL LEWIS: I think the thing to
remember as well is we keep
saying that that background
page is the hub.
And if you were going to do
this, you would do that kind
of magic iFrame smooshing-in
kind of
methodology, wouldn't you?
To be like here's
a new window.
Smoosh in everything I need.
Off you go.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I mean, we've played around
with Web Intents.
I keep saying this.
I'm known for Web Intents
and pushing it.
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
That's a shock to me.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, I know.
I do, you know.
I warn you now.
We'll talk about it.
But yeah, the idea behind Web
Intents was Web Intents inside
Chrome applications--
they opened up--
basically they just called
on-launched again, so it's
like launching a brand new
version of the application
each time you call it.
But your entire application
was constructed and
componentized out of
defined actions.
So in this case, I mean,
this is not a great
example for Web Intents.
It's not a great example.
No, it's a good example.
I'm joking.
PAUL LEWIS: I am mortally
offended.
PAUL KINLAN: The general idea
was that you might have like
an edit function, a view
function, and different
components inside
your application
with different views.
And you'd want third parties to
be able to kind of edit an
image, or view an image using
your application.
But what about yourself,
right?
Do you want to be able to have
to manage all that in a
completely different way than
the Web Intents client would?
And so we played around with
the idea of saying, well,
every single app inside your
application is just an intent.
So you basically say I'm going
to fire a brand-new window.
I'm going to fire an intent.
Find me an application.
I know the applications myself,
so I just call my
on-launched event and
pass the data in.
And then the system goes, well,
I know I need to make a
brand-new window.
Open it up and put
your data in.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
So in that sense, so you're
saying if I had an application
that could edit an image, it
doesn't matter whether
internally I say dispatch the
Web Intent to edit an image,
or somebody else says
dispatch the Web
Intent to edit an image.
PAUL KINLAN: It's
all the same.
PAUL LEWIS: It's all kind
of handled the same way.
It kind of standardizes and
homogenizes that interface to
your application, doesn't
it, I suppose.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, and uses
the same logic that an
external party would
use as well.
It's kind of nice.
It didn't work.
PAUL LEWIS: But it
will, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it will.
There was a bug where you
couldn't fire an intent on
your application, which
I hope will be fixed.
At least it should be.
Otherwise, I'll go and
crack some whips.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Well, that'll be fun.
PAUL KINLAN: That'll
work, won't it?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, it's never
going to be a problem.
PAUL KINLAN: But yeah, we were
talking about this with
Angular as well.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: We haven't quite
worked it out just yet.
But we were talking about having
your entire application
user interface defined
in one HTML file.
And then certain directives--
and those directives, for
instance, in Angular, which
say make this area
a modal dialog.
You basically call it.
It makes a modal dialog
inside your page.
Well, if we can inject content
into web pages, why can't we
inject that kind of
modal dialogue?
It's not necessarily
a modal dialog.
We haven't got modal
dialog in this.
It doesn't directly
inject them in.
It just basically says, well,
I'm going to inject the HTML
and JavaScript content in my
controller, and my view, and
all that type of stuff in.
And you've got it coming out,
and you've just got one HTML
resource as the window.
And we're open to
experimentation, right?
PAUL LEWIS: I was going
to say this.
And I'm glad you said this.
We're keen to get feedback.
The question is--
coming back around,
is NVC dead?
Should we move on?
No, it's not dead.
No.
Go with the methodologies that
you're comfortable with.
We're keen to see
how you get on.
So just let us know.
That's really the general
gist, but no, I
don't consider it dead.
Next question, then.
PAUL KINLAN: So the next
question, "Does multiple
window message pass-in require
the Beta version of Chrome?
Or will it work with the current
Stable version?"
That's from Chris from
Philadelphia.
So this is very much in the
Dev channel at the moment.
The Chrome Apps system
which are--
well, the aim is to make these
applications look and feel
native on the desktop, right?
They're not quite ready for
Stable channel just yet.
The APIs are still evolving.
So they're very much behind
the Canary branch and Dev.
At some point soon, they should
roll out into Beta.
And once they roll out into
Beta, they go into Stable.
The interesting thing just
generally is that--
sorry, I'm just seeing a
Web Intent question.
I should not look at
other screens.
So the thing is they're
not there just yet.
They will come soon.
And then this will be available
for those types of
applications also.
So it's pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: What was that Web
Intents question then? "Chrome
extensions on Web Intents?
Best mates or oil and water?"
PAUL KINLAN: Best mates.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, there's
a shock.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Color
me surprised.
Why are they best mates?
PAUL KINLAN: Because the whole
of Chrome is a best mate with
Web Intents.
PAUL LEWIS: I like it.
PAUL KINLAN: So when you look at
a lot of things to do with
Web Intents-- can we
just try actually?
Go back to the screen.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah?
Where are we going?
What are we doing?
PAUL KINLAN: Right.
Can we go to a site,
your blog.
Can we go to your blog?
aerotwist.com.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, interesting.
Excellent.
Look at that.
I'm joining Google.
PAUL KINLAN: When are
you joining Google?
PAUL LEWIS: already did.
PAUL KINLAN: Really?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Oh, look at these!
Some tutorials.
PAUL KINLAN: Sweet.
So click on the little
plus button.
Share this page.
PAUL LEWIS: I would love to.
PAUL KINLAN: This
fires Intents.
So we don't have any
of these installed.
So what happens here is there's
actually three or four
different applications.
None of them are installed.
Share to--
is this--
what type of email is this?
Is this a--
PAUL LEWIS: No.
PAUL KINLAN: --personal
email address?
PAUL LEWIS: This is
completely fresh.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, we'll
give it a go, right?
Oh wait, tell you what.
Let's share with Gmail.
See what happens.
We won't actually see any data
come through, but add it and
come through.
So what's happened here is
that we've redirected.
Could we jump back from the code
now and then just go to
our pretty face?
So what's actually happened here
is that we've actually
passed the data from the share
intent straight through to an
application.
It can be a Chrome application,
old packaged app,
new packaged app,
hosted website.
So it could be say, a cloud
file, [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: Could it
be an extension?
PAUL KINLAN: And an extension.
So this is not Gmail directly
supporting Intents right now.
This is me writing an extension
which uses Intents.
PAUL LEWIS: So it
passes through.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, basically.
So all of the Intents
system is built
off the back of Chrome.
And irregardless of whether it's
an extension, the host of
that normal web application or
website, or an application,
they will all work together.
PAUL LEWIS: Wow.
Best mates, indeed.
PAUL KINLAN: Best buddies.
Definitely not oil and water.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
So next question--
"How do I manage supporting
users-- we might as well
answer this question.
We're not going to have a good
answer, I don't think.
"How do I manage supporting
users on all the Chrome
versions, eg, 15 on Ubuntu.
I can see breaking changes
around Version 18, but the
docs pre-18 are no
longer available.
My specific problem is around
send message and send
request."
I think the best thing to do
is send that to the Chrome
Extensions group or the Chrome
Apps group on Google Groups of
all places.
Or ask on Stack Overflow,
because we monitor Stack
Overflow as well.
The actual documentations, we
try to keep the documentation
in line with what is mostly
in production.
So Stable is where, I presume,
like 99.9% of
all our users are.
I don't know the exact
figures there.
But the majority of everyone's
on Stable, which at the
moment is on 22.
Beta, I believe, is
still 22 as well.
It might change to
23 at some point.
Dev is 23 going on 24, those
types of things.
So we tend to only keep
documentations for what is
really, really applicable.
Because we're an auto-updating
framework, the number of users
outside is pretty small.
But that being said, we want to
make sure you can have your
questions answered.
And you could do that
in Stack Overflow.
Tag it with either Google
Chrome or Chrome
App I think is the--
PAUL LEWIS: Google Chrome App.
PAUL KINLAN: Google
Chrome App, is it?
PAUL LEWIS: I think so.
PAUL KINLAN: Or Chrome
Extensions.
Google Chrome Extension,
I believe it will be.
Tag them up there, and
away you will go.
And someone will try and answer
your question as best
as possible.
So do we have any
more questions?
PAUL LEWIS: We do.
Sorry if this is out of topic.
It says Luciano. "What
are the deploy
options for Chrome Apps?
If I'm using Google Apps for
Business can I deploy only on
my organization?
PAUL KINLAN: This is
a good question.
So we have good support for
Apps organizations.
If you go to the developer
dashboard, chrome.google.co
m/webstore/developer/dashboard,
That's where basically you
manage your applications.
And if you're inside a Google
Apps domain, I believe it very
much depends on the policy that
your admins have set.
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely
it does, yes.
PAUL KINLAN: So you can either
publish locally to your own
/a/yourdomain kind of web store,
which will have the
rest of the web store in
if the administrator's
technically enabled it.
But it'll have just your
applications and only your
users will be able
to see them.
That being said, if you make an
application and you want to
host it, publish it using your
own Google Apps domain, you
can still do that, and
you can still publish
it publicly as well.
PAUL LEWIS: Awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: So, yeah,
that should work.
And the thing right now is we
don't have the ability to
support these new Chrome
apps just yet.
I hope it's soon.
And we'll let you know as soon
as that happens because it
will be a joyous day.
PAUL LEWIS: But do start
playing with it.
Because when that does happen,
you can have your
apps ready to fly.
And that's a lot of users
that get to play with
your shiny new app.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So I'm apologizing for looking
away from the camera.
PAUL LEWIS: Got any
more questions?
PAUL KINLAN: So Terry Davis.
"With this practice, can you
code a floating YouTube video
that can have an adjusted
transparency?"
PAUL LEWIS: So the floating
window thing--
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: --yes, we
can do because--
PAUL KINLAN: The transparency,
no.
PAUL LEWIS: The transparency,
PAUL KINLAN: There is actually
an open book about this.
We would like you to be able to
have the ability for you to
say, well, different parts of
your Chrome are transparent.
We can have the ability to do a
lot with the Chrome in your
Chrome application right now.
But not transparency.
PAUL LEWIS: But the floating
window thing, you can, for
example, set.
When you create that window,
if you remember back to my
code, I had the createWindow
going on.
In the object that you pass
through where I had the width
on the left, you can actually
add frame as an extra property
and then set none.
And that will get rid of the
bar at the top and all the
rest of it, so it's actually
just a window.
So you can then drop in some
YouTube goodness into there.
So you can do that.
And then also we've got a bug
open for transparency.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: I think
we're at the end
of our general questions.
I do want to talk one more time
about the windows and the
window in APIs.
We are definitely open for
consideration of how you want
to build applications with
the window in API.
We do have some examples on
GitHub, and we'll share them
out later on.
I'm just cleaning some of
them up little bit.
But both Censure and Kendo
made two applications.
One is a video streamer that
connects to your media center
on your local network.
Pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: That
sounds amazing.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it does
UPnP broadcast, all
that type of stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: Sweet!
PAUL KINLAN: It's nice.
They actually built their own
method for routing messages
between them.
So there's some pop-up
frameworks you can get in
JavaScript.
I think it's JPopup
of all names.
And basically, the idea behind
that was to have this
background page orchestrate all
the logic, especially when
you're in sandbox.
We didn't really touch that
today with the sandbox.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
PAUL KINLAN: If your application
is in sandbox, I
don't believe you can actually
get access to
the background page.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
PAUL KINLAN: You have
to post message.
PAUL LEWIS: Post message.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So if you need to use eval and a
new function and you have to
have the sandbox attribute
for your
application, you will be--
I think you have to use--
PAUL LEWIS: Kind of
what I was saying.
Actually, that does apply
if you are using say, a
templating engine.
Most of the time, they use
eval or new function.
To get those to work seamlessly,
then you do put
them into a sandbox.
So you would use that, as Paul
said, the post message thing.
I think the only framework I'm
aware of is Angular right now,
that It doesn't need--
PAUL KINLAN: Backbone.
You can use Backbone
to some extent.
The only thing is the
[INAUDIBLE] on the template,
which you can work around
quite easily.
But generally, Backbone
work perfectly.
Kendo, I believe, censured
the use of the sandbox
system, so they use--
but it's kind of cool because
it abstracts your view and
your logic, awake quite nicely
inside the background page, so
it's pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: Also, what we didn't
cover today, I believe
we covered in a previous week,
was the minimize and maximize.
You've got also other methods
that you can call on the
windows, which as I say,
we didn't cover today.
But you can find the
documentation on
developers.chrome.com/apps.
And that covers things like
minimize, maximize, and--
PAUL KINLAN: You know what is
interesting I found the other
day scanning the docs?
PAUL LEWIS: Shoot.
PAUL KINLAN: If you put "trunk"
before "apps," you get
the very latest documentation.
And TCP Listener looks like it
is in the latest version.
PAUL LEWIS: Service
in the browser.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
So we have the ability to do
UDP service in the browser
because we have BIND, which
is pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: It is amazing.
PAUL KINLAN: The biggest one
people want, though, is the
ability to do a TCP server
in the background.
So you could basically run an
HTTP server inside your
application.
PAUL LEWIS: And the web
serving the web--
PAUL KINLAN: Indeed.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh!
PAUL KINLAN: It's like oh!
PAUL LEWIS: Wow.
PAUL KINLAN: It's pretty cool.
But that's actually pretty
cool because we get the
ability to do nice things.
I haven't tested it to
see if it works.
I'm presuming, though, the
documentation is there.
Then there's a good chance that
at least the AP-- well,
I'll rephrase it.
The documentation generates
off the API information.
So at least it means the
stubs are there.
Whether the actual
implementation is there is a
different thing.
But yeah, we have this ability
to do some really potentially
awesome stuff around
networking.
Eric Bidelman-- so we ran
a hackathon internally.
PAUL LEWIS: Certainly did.
PAUL KINLAN: Eric Bidelman
was trying to
do something similar.
We couldn't do it.
Basically he was saying I want
to be able to develop a My
Chromebook.
So My Chromebook.
We always get questions
about Chromebooks.
He wants to be able to develop
on his Chromebook, but also
host it and test his
application.
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: So the idea is
basically like I don't want to
have to go out, FTP it
up somewhere, and
test it that way.
I just want to be able to run a
basic web server to test my
content and view it inside
the browser.
PAUL LEWIS: So TCP Listener
is exactly what
you need for that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
That's the aim , is TCP Listener
is that exact thing.
That's the first use case
I can think of.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, it's
a good one in all.
PAUL KINLAN: I think
it's pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
PAUL KINLAN: I can't imagine
SMTP servers in the browser.
PAUL LEWIS: There's a
whole world there.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: It's
pretty awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: So anyway, we would
actually like to know
what type of things that
you want to hear
from us in the future.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Will I be
on my own next time?
PAUL LEWIS: I don't know.
We'll find out, won't we?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
We'll see what happens.
PAUL LEWIS: Tune in.
Oh, to find out.
PAUL KINLAN: Ideally, we want
to try and get more very
specific application
information--
so show you applications running
rather than just show
some of the raw APIs.
I will deep dive into
those APIs.
But we'll give you a
good overview of
what's going to happen.
I really want to talk about
the browser type, because
that's one of those things
that's going
to be pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, especially
how that differs
from like my an iFrame.
Because that has
come up before.
How does this differ?
So we can cover up
that as well.
PAUL KINLAN: We'll
cover up that.
We'll do a whole load of
stuff around storage.
You'll do some playing
around with that.
Image downloading
at one point.
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
I know Eric Bidelman
covered it.
But hopefully, we'll get
a library out at some
point soon I hope.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank you very
much for joining us.
PAUL KINLAN: It's a little
bit short today.
I'm very sorry about the
questions and answers, just
pure because I--
So what It was, I didn't set
it up correctly completely.
I set the questions to
end as we started,
not end as we finished.
PAUL LEWIS: This is quite
cathartic for you, isn't it?
To just share this out
to the internet.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Dear internet--
PAUL KINLAN: Dear internet--
PAUL LEWIS: I'm sorry.
PAUL KINLAN: --I'm sorry.
PAUL LEWIS: There
you go, you see?
Feel better?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
And also--
ooh!
We have another question.
Can we continue?
I think we can.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, we haven't
said goodbye.
PAUL KINLAN: We haven't
PAUL LEWIS: This is the
joy of the liveness.
PAUL KINLAN: So if you're into
British comedy, we have a
surprise for you later.
PAUL LEWIS: No, don't do that.
Yeah, we did it.
PAUL KINLAN: We did it.
It's put the pressure on.
PAUL LEWIS: No, I like it.
And we'll forget.
I'll be fine.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's "Heymonth."
I think that's how
we pronounced it.
I got it from, I think,
Bangalore again.
PAUL LEWIS: "What was that
about magic iFrames?"
PAUL KINLAN: "Magic iFrames.
"I saw a proposal to remove
it." Yes, I heard about a
proposal to remove the magic
iFrames work as well.
The reason why-- well,
I say the reason why.
I don't know the full
reason why.
I wouldn't be surprised because
no one really knew how
it ever worked.
I never saw any documentation.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
PAUL KINLAN: You search Google
for magic iFrames.
You get a page mention in magic
iFrames and not exactly
what it was.
But that was the idea, is you
could start to inject content
and bridge an iFrame between
two windows.
So you've got open window, well,
the window reference off
window.open.
You basically put
the iFrame in.
But no one ever knew
how to do it.
But if you ever saw that's live,
share them, out and I'll
share them on Google
and Twitter.
I'm Paul Kinlan on Google+.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm Paul
Lewis on Google+.
PAUL KINLAN: But you have a
funny name on Twitter, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Aerotwist.
PAUL KINLAN: Aerotwist.
Why is that?
PAUL LEWIS: It's just because
they're apparently--
and this was a shock
to me, but there
are other Paul Lewises.
And some of them are like a
famous pianist, a journalist.
So that left me no choice.
I had to come up with
another name.
So Aerotwist it is.
PAUL KINLAN: That's a
pretty cool name.
PAUL LEWIS: It's all
right, yeah.
It sort of works.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm lucky
that Kinlan is not a
very popular name.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
So what are you going to do?
Roll with it I think is what
you're going to do.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, yes.
There was an actor called
Jim Kinlan.
But that doesn't
mean anything.
It's not really the same.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, this is a
thrilling end-on topic.
So with that said--
PAUL KINLAN: So with
that said--
PAUL LEWIS: It's goodnight
from me--
PAUL KINLAN: And it's
goodnight from him.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes!